hello can you hear me well yeah okay so
welcome everyone to my talk how to
increase diversity in open source
projects I'm Marlon Westerman and yeah a
few more words about me I am from
Oldenburg and Germany near Bremen
represented by the Bremen Town musicians
in the top corner of the slide I did a
PhD on the intersection of agricultural
and environmental science at the
University of Queensland in Brisbane
Australia
and after that I transitioned to data
science and after that to machine
learning and now at Deutsche Bahn I am
actually responsible for using machine
learning to reduce delays
it doesn't work out over time you know
where to complain
um
yeah I'm an active contributor to open
source as Hana highlighted and I'm also
a Pilates Bulletin co-organizer
so let's talk about diversity
so I've got a definition of diversity
here that I really like it's by the
Linux foundation and I'll read it out to
you
so
they say we Define diversity within open
source communities as a pluralism of any
number of the following possibilities
gender identity and expression race
ethnicity sexual orientation age social
class cast language
physical and neurological ability or
attributes religious beliefs value
systems national origin and political
affiliation
so now that we have an understanding of
what diversity is let's look at the
state of diversity in open source
projects let's look at some data
so the Linux Foundation today's survey
and they found that among open source
contributors 82 percent of people
identify as male 14 of people identify
as female and only four percent of
people identify with other genders
and when you look at the number of
female core developers among open source
projects you find that only five percent
of Open Source projects actually have
female core Developers
let's look at ethnic diversity so you
can see here on the slide that 36
percent of contributors come from the
USA alone followed by 36 percent of
contributors from all across Europe
followed by 15 from the asia-pacific
region followed by eight percent from
Central and South America
followed by only five percent from
Africa and the Middle East
so you can see that there's a strong
over representation of people from the
global North
and I could go over more examples of
diversity such as age distribution or
identification
[Music]
with the lgbtqi community for example
but we only unfortunately have 30
minutes so I wanted to show you two
examples and we can talk more about
other aspects of diversity later
so what are the consequences of this
lack of diversity
there are consequences for the
underrepresented groups as well as for
open source projects
for people belonging to underrepresented
groups the consequences are mainly loss
of opportunities such as loss of skill
development or lack of skill development
and not such good career advancement
possibilities
for open source projects the
consequences are mainly a lack of
diversity of perspectives which leads to
lower problem solving capacity less
robust Technologies
lower productivity we know this today
and also as a skept ability to unhealthy
work environments
so in summary diversity means resilient
and if you have low diversity on your
open source project it means that is
that it has a reduced ability to adapt
to change
so if you if you are running an open
source project and you want it to be
successful in the long run you better
have good diversity
so before we talk about the strategies
what you can do to have a better
diversity on your team let's look at the
challenges that people face like why
why is the diversity so low in open
source project
and the challenges are mainly social
such as lack of peer parity or
non-inclusive communication
or a toxic culture as I just mentioned
or expectation issues people might be
expected to take on Advanced tasks very
soon without the appropriate support
or there might be gender biasing or
stereotyping for example women might be
expected to take on communication tasks
there's also the problem of imposter
syndrome I once found a really good
definition of imposter syndrome I think
I wasn't it was on Twitter and it was
high expectations low support
so many people from underrepresented
groups in Tech are actually career
changes so they often need a bit more
support and this is why so many people
from these groups suffer from imposter
syndrome
and there are also issues such as
work-life balance issues
for example many women still carry out
the majority of care tasks for example
most it's mostly women who do aged care
work or who do Child Care work mostly
non-paid and so often women simply have
less time
and then there are other challenges such
as language access in many parts of the
world
English education is not great and so
people struggle with contributing to
open source because generally the
default language of Open Source projects
is English and so that is a barrier
then there are also educational access
problems like for example people might
not be able to attend
conferences or hackathons or internships
simply because they like the finances or
the time
then their Geographic access problems
especially when you lived in Oceania
like me I mean I lived in a wealthy
country Australia but if you for example
live in Fiji and you would like to
attend
conferences or meetings mostly these
meetings are at night time for you and
it's really not a great time for you to
attend meetings
and also and staying with the example of
Fiji you might not have constant
reliable internet access in many
countries developing countries for
example there's simply no stable
internet connection or even not not even
a stable electricity Supply
and then there are also economic and
professional access problems such as
many people are not compensated for
their open source contributions
and sometimes employers don't approve of
people doing open source contributions
either during work hours or even outside
of work hours because employers are
sometimes afraid that Knowledge from
within the company might leak into open
source projects which I find a bit crazy
but okay
and then there is also generally a lack
of sponsorships and mentorships
so now that we understand the challenges
what are some of the strategies that we
can apply to address these problems
one important strategy is to use
inclusive language such as don't use
guys use more inclusive language such as
folks you can say high folks or hi
everyone
and also if you have a master Branch
please rename it to Maine if you have
master and slave nodes please use
primary secondary or other language
also try to avoid saying man hours
please save engineer or even better
personal hours
also please don't use the derogatory
terms such as so simple your mother can
do it it's better to use user-friendly
for example
and also please don't assume someone's
gender
you simply don't know how someone
identifies in terms of gender until you
ask them or unless it is written
somewhere for example on their social
media profiles
so always ask for people to pronounce
then I would also like to highlight a
good contributing to documentation this
is important and it's also important to
keep it up to date and I would like to
highlight an example here on the left
hand side from pandas
um it was about eight months ago that I
tried to contribute to pandas and I
simply wasn't able to install the deaf
version of pandas I tried to follow the
contributing to documentation but it was
quite outdated and On guitar where
people can go and ask questions I
noticed that other people have the same
problem and so I opened an issue and so
together with the team members of pandas
the issue got fixed and now with pandas
2.00 the contributing to pandas
documentation is up to date and it works
at least on unix-based systems
um not sure about Windows systems I
don't have a Windows computer but if you
are on a Windows computer and you would
like to contribute to open source I can
highly recommend to install Windows
subsystem for Linux because that makes
your life a whole lot easier and I would
also like to highlight
please don't shame open source core
members for not having an up-to-date
contributing to documentation many open
source projects such as pandas are
mainly run by volunteers and they are
really busy busy with just maintaining
the project and so sometimes they simply
don't have the time to keep the
documentation up to date and so for
example me opening the issue was
actually welcome so and yeah it was
really it was really great and it was
really great for me to see that this got
fixed
and then also I have an example here
from scikit-learn
quite regularly when I contribute to
psychic learn it happens to me that I
run Pi test and then I get an import
error and then I realize like oh okay
some thyson files have probably been
updated and I need to do a recompile and
I need and I do a recompile and this is
pretty standard and I realized that this
is actually not really documented on the
contributing to cycle learn page and so
I opened an issue for that and the
maintainers Really welcome that because
they realized oh yeah this actually
isn't really documented and actually
this is a barrier for people when they
try to contribute to open source
projects or like in this case I could
learn
and So currently it's still under
discussion how to best update the
documentation but soon it should be
updated as well
so if you find such issues or such
problems um feel free to open an issue
at the prospective open source project
and generally your contribution will be
really welcome because often maintainers
are so experienced they don't even
realize what barriers are for new
contributors
then what's also really important is to
have contributing to documentation in
different languages data umbrella for
example who have run a lot of Sprints
together with scikit-learn and also
other projects they for example run a
workshop for people targeted
target targeted for people sorry for
people from Southern America
and so what that did was that they
translated the contributing to psychic
learn documentation to Spanish and
Portuguese and this was really helpful
for people actually
and then you can also be encouraging and
welcoming that's also a great strategy
so for example when you see a new
contributor you can say thanks a lot for
your contribution we really value your
contribution and here at the bottom I'm
showing an example of my first pull
request to psychic learn where Thomas
one of the co-developers said I see this
was your first time contributing welcome
and it did make me feel more welcome I
found this was really nice
and I also have an example from the
pandas project
I then started contributing to pandas
after I figured out how to install the
development version of pandas and I made
a pull request and
um
on one day Marco gorelli one of the core
contributors he made a pull request
review and on that day I was I was not
having a great day I was feeling sick
and then I looked at my notifications
and I saw that he included a really cute
cat gif in his pull request review and I
have to say it made my day and I found
it was it was just really cute and yeah
I'm I'm advocating for more acute gifs
or photos and pull request reviews
10 minutes left okay oops good
um well okay then I think I have to
speed up a little bit
you can also promote specific groups and
events through exam for example you can
run events through
organizations such as Pilates or women
in machine learning and data science and
there are also other groups that are
targeted towards underrepresented
underrepresented people in Tech
and it's also important to like and
share social media posts to increase
visibilities invisibility and you can
also run events in schools and
universities and give priority to people
from underrepresented groups
and what you can also do as I just said
before you can run online events
targeted at people from geographically
underrepresented regions
then it's also important to promote
awareness of the presence of peers for
example at conferences like these you
can make sure you have good speaker
diversity and please also promote on
social media for example Pilates Berlin
has been highlighting all the high
ladies speakers of this conference so
please
like and tweet retweet and you can also
if you run
workshops targeted at people from
underrepresented groups in Tech write
blog articles about it you can also do
contributor interviews with people from
underrepresented backgrounds so that you
increase the visibility visibility of
these people
and in general it's always good and
important to recognize people's
achievements
then please don't
stereotype open software open sorry open
source software contributors
don't automatically assign Community
Building tasks for example to
underrepresented groups it's better to
spread the workload and please don't
refer to your female developers as
female or women developers to say
developers to be more inclusive
then another really important strategy
is to have mentorship and I'm citing
here leaders at the mentorship program
at the Linux Foundation they said that
mentorship is invaluable to improving
diversity and inclusion in open source
communities because it lowers barriers
to entry and onboarding and it really
helps with networking and it helps
Junior contributors to being able to
establish themselves and it also really
helps new contributors with career
development
and I would like to highlight this book
by Athena Rising it's called how and why
men should Mentor women I haven't read
it yet but apparently it's a great book
so please go ahead and read it
and I would also like to highlight two
more examples so I would like to point
out that I'm not getting paid by any of
the open source projects or companies
I'm presenting here and I'm not getting
any benefits I'm just highlighting
examples that I have come across now
cycle learn is running a five-month paid
internship for people to contribute to
open source sorry to contribute to
scikit-learn and is targeted towards
underrepresented groups in Tech and one
side is currently running a very similar
initiatives and these initiatives simply
weren't there a couple of years ago and
so this is really great to see
then another Point that's really
important is to have good governance
ideally you have a governance board and
ideally there is transparency around how
our leaders determined and how our
contributors onboarded and managed and
supported and it's important to have
transparent career pathways
and it's important to promote people
from underrepresented groups to
leadership roles
and it's really important to Value
non-coding contributions to the project
for example if you have a Communications
team please also value the the
contributions of the community
Communications team
and it's a really good idea to not have
a technical committee but to have a
steering committee for example which
also includes people from for example
the communications team
and it's also good to have a triaging
team a triaging team as a team where
people have access right access to
GitHub and they can label and edit
issues for example and it's also
important to make incremental changes
over time please don't go ahead and like
fully restructure everything because
people need to adapt to changes and you
need to give them the time and space to
adapt to them
and then the last point is to create and
enforce a code of conduct
a code of conduct can signal to
marginalized people at the open source
Community cares and it provides guidance
for newcomers and provides reference for
core values and norms
and yeah it's really important to have a
dedicated code of conduct team or if you
don't have the time to deal with it you
can also hire professionals to follow up
on Code of Conduct breach reports
and now I would like to highlight some
literature many points that I have
presented today come from the research
of Bianca drinking rice she has done a
lot of research on diversity and
inclusion in software
so yeah please go ahead and read her
research she's amazing she does amazing
work
and I would also like to highlight this
book that recently came out by Professor
Christina Dunbar hesta it's called
hacking diversity
and she has done extensive research on
diversity in open source communities
and her conclusion is that
the lack of diversity stems from an
unequal cultural distribution of Social
Power
and so
her point is that because of that it's
really hard to increase diversity in
open source projects and I have to say
that
initially that made me feel a bit
powerless because I thought like okay so
there's a wider systemic issue and so
so should we just
put our hands in our labs and wait for
our society in general to change or what
um but that's not the point she's me
she's making so she's saying that it's
hard but
I mean it's also not impossible I've
seen it in the professional world like
the
um
like the non-open source world
at the industry world
that it is possible to create really
diverse teams and I find that open
source projects are in a powerful
position because they are so widely used
and people have a look at them and look
at who is actually Behind these projects
and so if we manage to
build diverse open source communities
this can have a strong ripple effect
and
I could tell a lot of stories about how
even just one person really made a
difference
but I would like to conclude my talk
with saying that everyone can make a
difference so each of you here can
definitely make a difference and
contribute to improving diversity in
open source so thanks a lot these are my
references and I'm also on social media
you can find me on Macedon Twitter
LinkedIn GitHub whichever you prefer and
thanks for listening
[Applause]
thank you for this great talk Aaron
there are some questions you can still
ask questions as well and so the first
question is
a very true
again another event about diversity
almost empty in an event full of white
male Global no others
how to address that
I think it's actually not a question for
you but the people who didn't come I
would love to go outside and ask them
but yeah
do you have an answer
yeah I mean
when you want to build diverse
communities you need a lot of
persistence and patience and I Can See
For example that at this conference
there are many more women or at least
ISU so I mean as I said you should never
um you should never
um you should never assume someone's
gender
but I can see a lot more the a lot more
diversity this year for example than
last year and I feel like slowly things
are changing but the change is slow
unfortunately and I think we all need to
work together to push for better
diversity
here it was the diversity was the
keynote so maybe that's also an option
yeah
um
the next question is some people propose
that the GitHub account should be
agnostic to gender identity what do you
think
that is a good point
but it's also hard right like I mean
again like you should never assume
someone's gender but like when people
have a photo on their GitHub account I
have a photo like people generally
assume someone's gender so I mean
you could force everyone to not have a
photo
but then it's also becoming very
impersonal
it's a very tricky question yeah yeah I
think so too then also everybody had to
have like a gender neutral nickname and
not like appear with their like real
name
yeah it has definitely happened to me
that
um I have been discriminated because of
my appearance but that was on stack
Overflow like I answered on stack
Overflow and an hour later my answer was
deleted even though it was relevant
yeah okay and and stack Overflow you
appear with your like name and your
picture
um the next question is the example
shown were very big projects two smaller
projects with only a few maintainers
need to apply a different strategy to be
more inclusive
that's a good question
I wouldn't maybe I wouldn't say
necessarily different strategies but I
think smaller projects have more
leverage because they're smaller and so
there are less
people you need to have a consensus with
so I think you can
I think you can potentially act faster I
think it's an advantage Maybe
fully
yep
okay one more question over there coming
more
let me
um
have a look
how to win people from Milwaukee's where
the use of Open Source techno technology
as a possible hobby is unknown
yeah that is a really good question
something that I would really like to do
is to go into high schools especially in
noikon where I live in Norco and there
are many people from especially the
Middle East many people from lower
socio-economic backgrounds and I would
really love to run workshops there for
free for for the school students
unfortunately my time is limited
but I really hope that maybe in the
future I can collaborate with
organizations to to do such things
the next question is are there
initiatives by men for help with male
fragility in open source
similar to coaching in white only groups
working against their own racism
sorry could you repeat that other
initiatives by men for helping like for
help was made for fragility in open
source so I think if they are like
initiatives for men where they can ask
themselves about them and like their
male fragility
hmm
how do I answer the question I think
it's really important to be a good Ally
and to not judge people for example I
mean we all make mistakes I also make
mistakes sometimes and
when I do I I feel
but it is also important that when we
make mistakes that we don't judge people
for that and don't be like hey you're
you're an or something like that
I think it's really important that we
say like hey I understand that you
didn't do this on purpose and I can see
that this wasn't your attention to to
hurt someone
so I think it's really important to to
be a good Ally and say like hey we all
need to do better we're all learning and
to generally be supportive
the next question is on GitHub
also being anonymous is necessarily
positive we should encourage diverse
people to be open about their diversity
so this is not not a question but a
comment
um and also another comment
it helps also to have a training for
bystander intervention and for allyship
to get knowledge where our problems I
don't know I don't get the product the
comment
did you get it is it the question no
okay yeah
um
no more no more questions so far anybody
yeah but it's also
time's up so that's the question much I
one last one yeah
yes in uh many in many especially the
smaller projects there is a very
difficult
um
diverse contributor to get on board
namely the first one
do you have any hints on
how to how to support that first person
or how to find
find them because I think they have a
much harder time than the second one
that's a good point
come to Pilates events
and other events other meetups that
focus on underrepresented groups in Tech
I would say
and ask for support like if that's
available to you I mean often many
meetups are only in bigger cities and
and so you know some people need to
travel
but online support is also available for
example at Pilates we sometimes offer
speaker support and we also offer on
online contributing to various open
source projects to prod maybe something
in that direction
yeah
okay thank you very much modern
[Applause]